Biden's weekend that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right the Press hopes that the
past few days will make you forget just
how much money you've lost from bid
inflation from the high food and gas
prices and forget how much of the
country we've lost from the open border
and instead the media want you to be
impressed that Joe Biden could walk and
talk with President X the most effective
foreign policy leader since uh 41 Bush
41 uh he he's managing conflict EXT
extraordinarily he's got a great team
around him this is a big deal you two
men spent a lot of time together kind of
went for a walk reminds me of Reagan and
reic and gorbachov the most important
thing accomplished was simply the two
men spoke they were in a room together
trying to reset relations were they
watching the same Summit as the rest of
us uh I'm embarrassed I think it's CBS
but I can't remember who in CBS I'm
sorry
uh this yes
is all right you've heard of Weekend at
Bernie's well this was weekdays with
Biden the man was totally muddled and of
course his big donors all those
corporate Titans like Tim Cook
prostrating themselves before their dear
communist leader they came across as
clueless as bid himself like many others
in this room I believe that a strong and
prosperous China that supports and
invests in the International System can
be a force for good in the world the US
business community Community strongly
supports productive government toover
dialogue and progress in the
relationship we firmly believe that
continued economic growth in the United
States and China is essential to global
stability global stability now where
exactly has China been a force for
global stability um let me think Taiwan
uh Ukraine oh dealing with Hamas this is
just a bad joke at this point the fact
is big business long ago stopped being
about American jobs and American
manufacturing they claimed to care about
a lot of social justice issues but that
really only applies to when left-wing
groups are criticizing the United States
about things like race like after the
Floyd riots or climate change all the
time this was the pro-china trade Wall
Street journal's take on the matter Mr
shei received a standing ovation for
taking the stage before he said a word
and then the holess of Mr she's remarks
underscores how no one can claim they
attended to learn more about the opaque
intentions of the leader of the world's
second largest economy ouch oh as for
Biden's own Commerce Secretary who I
have to say is one of the dimmest bulbs
in an already low wattage cabinet well
she obviously thinks Biden's Global
appeal is going to help him for a
national us appeal in
2024 the world requires us
to manage this relationship responsibly
and to deliver on transnational
challenges like climate change and
Global Health that affect people around
the world now Republicans should just
hope that Gina keeps speaking out keeps
making the case because she is totally
out of touch with the concerns of
regular Americans oh by the way and
speaking of concern well Biden's
Secretary of State look at Tony blinkin
because he seemed very concerned
whenever Biden was left to speak on his
own move on his own during those days in
San Francisco check out the look on his
face when Biden answered a rather
uncomfortable question and Mr President
after today would you still refer to
presiden she as a dictator this is a
term that you used earlier this year
well look he is I mean he's a dictator
in the sense that he he is a guy who run
the country that is country that based
govern to different than our and look at
that facial expression as the Press was
being shed out of the meeting room
earlier that day I mean Biden's not I
mean blink's not a complete buffoon
because he knows that two-thirds of the
country are now saying America's on the
wrong track as a nation and he's
probably thinking to himself how is
putting Biden across the table from shei
going to help matters in that
regard uh and to that point a new
Marquette law school poll taken before
the summit has Trump up 4% nationally on
the very experienced Joe Biden then a
brand new Washington Post Monmouth
survey just came out shows support for
Trump's populist not globalist America
First approach to both domestic and
foreign policy is growing because
America look they they look and they see
what's happening around the world the
more money we spend the worse things
seem to get they're souring on Biden's
pet proxy war in Ukraine 51% of New
Hampshire GOP Primary vote ERS saying we
should not keep sending military aid and
as for the most important issues illegal
immigration tops the list now with 25%
saying it's the most important followed
by inflation and Rising prices at 20%
and then the justice department being
used for political purposes at
10% well nothing this week is going to
change the Public's overall view that
Biden is just in over his head on the
world stage
46% said they trust Trump more in
dealing with China compared to only 34%
who trust Biden more the American people
I think have caught on they're again
they're looking around they they see the
body language they see it all so they've
caught on to Biden's Global ass charade
and if anything I think the Summit is
only going to solidify that
position Americans who believe we should
remain a free and independent country
will view the shei Biden Summit as not a
strong start to a new beginning but a
weak end to an already hobbled us
position on the global stage and the
Biden presidency and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else